[Música]
mientras el conflicto entre israel y
hamas continúa cobrando víctimas en la
franja de gaza- los funcionarios
palestinos aseguraron que no se rendirán
por su parte el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de alemania de hua israel
para ayudar a un alto el fuego inmediato
un portavoz del movimiento islamista
hamás aseguró que un cese de
hostilidades probablemente tenga lugar
muy pronto
la ola migratoria en el enclave de ceuta
en españa parece estar controlada luego
de que más de 8000 migrantes africanos
intentarán entrar de forma irregular a
españa nadando ongs denuncian que las
fuerzas de seguridad vulnera los
derechos humanos de los migrantes y las
organizaciones la organización amnistía
internacional los pidió a marruecos
dejar de usar a sus propios ciudadanos
como peones de un juego político
la ola de protestas antigubernamentales
en colombia entro en su cuarta semana
cuando sindicatos grupos de
estudiantiles y varios ciudadanos
acudieron a marchas para exigir un
cambio social en medio de conversaciones
intermitentes entre el gobierno y los
organizadores de la huelga
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 sierra blanco como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
este informativo con el conflicto entre
israel y hamas donde no cesan las
hostilidades a pesar del llamado urgente
de la comunidad internacional el jefe de
la diplomacia alemana
heiko maas manifestó este jueves su
solidaridad con israel y pidió un alto
el fuego por su parte un portavoz de
hamas aseguró que un cese de
hostilidades probablemente llegue pronto
las víctimas han sido 12 muertos del
lado israelí mientras las autoridades
sanitarias palestinas reportan 228
fallecidos en su territorio
en las calles de gaza velan a un
periodista de la emisora laxa de hamás
you said abu hussein murió durante un
bombardeo nocturno mientras los
sobrevivientes asimilan los daños en
medio del dolor
galeana que ellos no estaban luchando
que estaban preparando el almuerzo en la
cocina cuando el golpe cayó sobre la
cocina y los mató y los quemó que ha
hecho una niña de tres años para merecer
morir quemada viva en la cocina
sientes que mi hermano y su esposa
estaban hechos pedazos en otros países
árabes mostraron su solidaridad hacia el
pueblo palestino
hoy enviamos un mensaje claro al mundo
de que el pueblo palestino no está solo
y que los estamos apoyando su causa es
nuestra causa los derechos de los
palestinos son los derechos de los
tunecinos la sangre palestina y la
tunecina es una y no olvidaremos esta
historia mientras en israel no hay
intenciones debes escalar los ataques
hacia la franja de gaza la comunidad
internacional pide al gobierno israelí
que baje la intensidad de la ofensiva
pero la lectura del primer ministro es
distinta dijo que está determinado
continuar hasta garantizar la paz
para el presidente de la autoridad
palestina israel está cometiendo
crímenes de guerra y aunque las
autoridades del grupo hamas prevén que
en pocos días existan las condiciones
para un cese el fuego
los bombardeos israel
y el lanzamiento de cohetes por parte de
hamás continuaron durante el día y la
noche del miércoles
y vamos ahora hasta europa donde
continúan las reacciones sobre la ola
migratoria que intentó entrar de manera
irregular a españa desde marruecos ante
esto las tropas militares españolas
siguen patrullando la frontera con
marruecos para evitar la llegada de más
migrantes desde que miles de ellos
intentaron cruzar la frontera entre
españa y ese país africano a través del
enclave de ceuta la actuación de la
policía y del gobierno español ha sido
cuestionada ongs denuncian que las
fuerzas de seguridad vulneraron los
derechos humanos de los migrantes esta
frontera que es una puerta a europa
lleva décadas e reforzando su seguridad
a través de los acuerdos entre españa y
marruecos para tratar de impedir esta
migración irregular lo repasamos con más
romero sal
una valla que desemboca en el mar y que
separa irremediablemente el norte global
del sur global es la frontera entre
ceuta el enclave español en el norte de
áfrica y marruecos 11 kilómetros
vigilados por las fuerzas de seguridad
españolas y marroquíes su objetivo
impedir la migración irregular desde el
continente africano hacia territorio
español
son casi tres décadas de colaboración
entre españa y marruecos una
colaboración que consiste en
externalizar las políticas migratorias
hacia marruecos para contener la llegada
de migrantes a cambio de altas sumas de
dinero el primer acuerdo entre los dos
países fue en 1992 un año después se
instalaron las vallas que separan ceuta
de marruecos y en 2002 terminó de
instalarse un sistema de alta tecnología
para controlar la frontera
desde entonces las bayas no han dejado
de crecer esta misma semana el gobierno
español aprobó una partida de 30
millones de euros para este tipo de
cooperación con marruecos
uno de los puntos más polémicos de los
acuerdos son las llamadas devoluciones
en caliente el retorno de migrantes
inmediatamente después de cruzar
irregularmente la frontera algunos
sistemas de justicia internacionales lo
consideran una práctica ilegal al no
esperar a determinar si los migrantes
tienen derecho a asilo o no antes de
volver a expulsarlos pero que en españa
se permite por los acuerdos bilaterales
con marruecos
que estas devoluciones sólo se
consideran legales si los migrantes son
mayores de edad y se detectan en su
intento de cruzar la frontera
unas premisas que organizaciones de
derechos humanos denuncian que no se han
cumplido con la reciente entrada masiva
de migrantes entre los que se cuentan
1.500 menores de edad de los cuales
muchos según estas denuncias habrían
sido devueltos en caliente a marruecos
y vuelve a juicio el ex presidente
francés nicolas sarkozy que será juzgado
por haber superado el techo de gasto
autorizado en la campaña de las
elecciones presidenciales del año 2012
sarkozy de 66 años fue condenado a
inicios de marzo a 3 años de cárcel
uno de ellos firme por corrupción y
tráfico de influencias pero apeló
inmediatamente el fallo lo que dejó en
suspenso el cumplimiento de esta pena en
este nuevo juicio de ser declarado
culpable podría ser condenado a un año
de prisión y a tener que pagar una multa
en colombia las protestas ciudadanas
llegan a su cuarta semana y medio del
descontento de gran parte de la
población hacia el gobierno del
presidente iván duque la desigualdad y
la falta de oportunidades en el país
ayer los colombianos volvieron a
manifestarse en varias ciudades de la
nación como en días anteriores las
protestas fueron mayoritariamente
pacíficas aunque hubo disturbios en
varios lugares y nuevas denuncias de
violencia policial según ongs 40 civiles
han muerto durante las movilizaciones y
por otra parte el presidente iván duque
nombró a la vicepresidenta marta lucía
ramírez como la nueva canciller del país
en reemplazo de claudia blum quien
renunció la semana pasada en plena
crisis
quiero designar a nuestra vicepresidenta
de la república la doctora marta lucía
ramírez de rincón como nueva canciller
de la república en esta oportunidad me
corresponde a mí en mantener en ese
cargo de la vicepresidencia pero
asumiendo ahora esta política exterior
que el presidente de la republica lidera
y para la cual vamos a trabajar en
permanente articulación con todas las
entidades del gobierno nacional pero
también con el sector privado y ante
esto también se conoció el día de ayer
que la agencia standard poor's redujo la
calificación de la deuda a colombia
continuamos la oficina regional de la
organización mundial de la salud para
europa aseguró que las vacunas contra el
cob en 19 aprobadas hasta la fecha son
eficaces contra todas las variantes sin
embargo instó a mantener la prudencia
sobre la evolución de esta pandemia y
aseguró que se trata de una amenaza
persistente y con nuevas incertidumbres
también les aseguro que el coi 19 no
permite aún reanudar de manera segura
los viajes internacionales
y es que varios países de américa
latina' encabezan la lista de los que
tienen más casos diarios de kobe 19 por
millón de habitantes en los últimos
siete días de los 15 países que tienen
más de 300 por millón casi la mitad son
de américa latina- uruguay argentina
exhiben las cifras más altas en el mundo
y suramérica con 301 casos por millón de
habitantes es la región del planeta más
afectada proporcionalmente veamos ahora
entonces como están en estos casos
diarios por millón de habitantes lo
encabeza uruguay con 874 y luego viene
argentina con 618 casos por millón de
habitantes le sigue costa rica con 474
paraguay con 323 colombia con 315 casos
por millón de habitantes brasil con 304
chile con 300 la fuente es de world in
data y los datos van hasta el 19 de mayo
de este año
y terminamos con una buena noticia para
los fanáticos de la popular serie
estadounidense friends que podrán
disfrutar de la tan esperada reunión de
los amigos neoyorquinos en la plataforma
de go max ayer miércoles estreno del
tráiler y dejó a ver muchos emocionados
pero tendrán que esperar hasta el 27 de
mayo en eeuu para poder disfrutar de
este reencuentro en el avance de casi 3
minutos de duración los protagonistas
conversan sobre lo que supuso el
programa para las carreras de ellos
también repasan guiones antiguos y
repiten su mítica noche de juego de
preguntas en el plato original de la
serie hasta aquí el informativo continua
con nosotros
[Música]